as brady singer
will face the angels for the first time
in his career
strike right in there so one of the
toughest men in baseball to strike out
takes a call third strike after singer
fell behind 2-0
mike trout in his nine full seasons
has been remarkable
strikeout this time on a slider
so singer has gotten fletcher and trout
and they're two down in the first inning
cobb ready to go to work in his second
regular season assignment
and a strikeout first of the night for
alex cobb nothing comes to the two-out
single
rolling into the second scoreless in kc
jared walsh digging in to start the
second we did in the first inning
i don't know that that's ever going to
happen again in angels history
as walsh is aboard second knock for the
halos tonight
justin upton at the plate for the angels
upton shoots it into the opposite field
[Applause]
bring up another angel who's going to be
pressed into full-time duty
jose rojas looking for his first big
league knock
nothing and won the count to rojas
drive out to a left center field rather
that chases
taylor he'll make the catch
[Applause]
[Music]
walsh advancing to third and it's a good
thing it was an errant throw here he
comes trying to score
throw to the plate gets away from perez
yikes
two runs come across
[Applause]
it'll be jorge solaire michael a taylor
and kyle isbell
the thing he got him got him with the
thing
another full count the 3-2 home to
taylor got him
swingy 2-2
got him swinging four straight
strikeouts for alex cobb
david fletcher who was called out on
strikes to begin the evening
fletch lines the ball to right laying
out his
isbell and he can't make the catch
stassy to third so two on and nobody out
to
shohei ohtani
perez is in st louis with that target
ground ball they missed the tag on
fletcher and get the out at first base
that brings a run into score it's three
nothing angels
and now two down to mike trout
nikki lopez from his knees on the grass
and santana
makes a nice pick over on the right side
and mike trout is down in the third
inning the angels had a run
oh man what a beauty
one down for nikki lopez the royals only
have one hit off of
cobb thus far
and lopez strikes out on three pitches
welcome to the thing
the thing is nasty tonight
and merrifield is rung up not an easy
man to strike out
six for alex cobb through three
scoreless innings to start the night
jared walsh leads things off in the
halos half of the fourth it'll be walsh
upton and rojas against brady singer
strikeout for brady singer that is his
fourth
the 2-2 is swung on and missed great
slider
man that was sweeping down and away from
justin upton
the o2 checked his swing did he go yes
he did
and brady stinger strikes out the side
in the fourth inning
alex cobb back to work and he has been
sharp so here's the one-two pitch
and did he go after that one yes he did
what do you say solaire breaks out of
his slide
like he said fastball
good job man i didn't think he was going
to throw it either
nowhere to hide in this part of the
angels order with ohtani trout and then
walsh
in the hold here we go second and third
with two gone
shohei bounces it back up the middle bad
hop
everybody safe
it looked like the royals were in the
right spot
but lopez took a terrible hop and it's
four
nothing angels
kyle isbell he struck out swinging in
the second
was that the thing or a breaking ball i
couldn't even tell
got him oh he just fouled it off at the
plate or did he he did not
oh the thang registering another punch
out for alex cobb
bottom of the sixth inning four nothing
angels and the royals have a little
something brewing here with
runners at first and second and one out
out over the plate
and lined to left field for a base hit
merrifield scores and salvi's 1000th hit
is an rbi you have been the backbone of
this organization since your first game
in tampa i'll never forget that
just the enthusiasm you bring to the
ballpark every day
it means so much not only to the rest of
the guys on the team
but also the thousands of people that
have watched you play over the years so
congratulations keep it going get as
many as you possibly can
and just remember one thing you're going
to be a royal for life
and now solaire on a 1-2 pitch drops it
into center
field and he's going to drive in two
takes a nice
inside out stroke and drives in a couple
to make it a one-run game
scott barlow is on with the royals down
by one runners at second and third with
two guns
here's the 1-1 to ohtani and that's hit
well into the corner
that'll rattle around and right and
clear the bases
[Applause]
one too many fastballs against shohei
ohtani
and the angels get their three-run lead
back in the seventh
the angels now have the bases loaded
with two outs and
justin upton will be the next batter
with a chance to do some
damage here banning with the bases
loaded biggest opportunity yet for the
angels to blow the game open and that
one bounces away from perez
ohtani scores 7-3 angels
[Music]
so fletcher's aboard to start the ninth
and that'll put a man on for shohei
otani who has done his share of the
damage once again tonight
[Applause]
shohei serves that into the opposite
field and that's going to drop in front
of ben and tindy
and rolled all the way to the track
fletcher coming around third and his
score
and it's an 8-3 angel lead more
damage by ohtani a single and a double
open the inning and now it's mike trout
and trout gets a hold of one into the
corner and left
daddy got it
homers in 10 straight two run
shot for trout i mean everything going
the halos way tonight